now South Korea says Pyongyang has fired
artillery shells into a buffer zone as
tensions escalate on the Korean
Peninsula the U.S and South Korea are
holding annual military exercises in the
city of yoju earlier around 250 shells
were fired into South Korea's Waters
from North Korea and speak now to Rob
McBride who joins us live now from yoju
so Rob just tell us what's happening
there now
that's right these exercises come at
this time of increasing tensions on the
Korean Peninsula these are annual drills
mainly involving South Korean forces all
of the different Services of the South
Korean Armed Forces but at various
places as we are here it also involves
uh detachments from the U.S contingent
here we're on a tributary of the Han
River about a couple of hours drive from
Seoul lahan river passes through Seoul
and what they've been doing here is
they've been conducting a river crossing
exercise setting up pontoon bridges
driving armor over the over the top of
these pontoon bridges really to develop
their skills in in river crossing as the
commanders here have been telling us
this the Korean peninsula there are a
lot of rivers it is the vital that they
have this skill if in Wartime they have
to use it it could be the difference
between success and failure as they have
told us but for the past few years South
Korea has avoided these large-scale
drill is partly because of covid they
these drills have been scaled back
sometimes they're just simulations
online sometimes they've been canceled
all together but mainly to allow
dialogue to take place to try to get the
North Koreans to talk about
denuclearization now as we know those
talks have failed they have come to
nothing so we've seen a resumption of
these large-scale military drills we
have these land drills we've just had
Naval drills off the east coast of the
Korean Peninsula that involved the
Ronald Reagan a U.S aircraft carrier
strike group it's the first time that
we've seen those sort of drills four or
five years according to the North
Koreans this is a a provocation
according to the South Koreans and their
allies it's because of these drills that
they guarantee stability it acts as a
deterrent it shows that the South and
their allies are standing firm and
there's a guarantee of peace and
stability on the Korean Peninsula but
we've seen the North Koreans reaction to
this with the firing of artillery
Tuesday through into a Wednesday morning
and then again Wednesday daytime and
crucially these shells a lot of them
falling in this buffer zone is a zone
that runs along the maritime and land
border when it was agreed in 2018 when
relations were a lot better than they
are now that military drills wouldn't be
carried out there because it acts as a
provocation there is a chance of a miss
a calculation or a mistake that could
lead to Untold consequences so we've
seen from South Korea the accusation
that this is a further provocation from
the north but with all other missile
activity that we've had from North Korea
the South Koreans have not been deterred
from their military drills and in fact
have announced that at the end of this
month we will see mass air drills
involving literally scores of planes
from the United States Air Force and
their South Korean counterparts
including the most up-to-date f-35s
all right Rob thanks for that Rob
McBride live for us there in yoju South
Korea